OK.
Good morning, everyone.
This is Jack Van Horn from the BD2K Training
Coordinating Center at the University of [? Southern
?] California.
And I'd like to welcome you all to our [INAUDIBLE]
Knowledge Guide to the Fundamentals of Data
Science.
Today we're going to be hearing from Daniela
Witten from the University of Washington in
Seattle on the subject of supervised machine
learning.
Dr. Witten earned her Bachelor's degree in
math and biology with honors and distinction
from Stanford University in 2005, and then
earned her PhD in statistics from Stanford
in 2010.
Since 2014, Daniela has been an associate
professor in statistics and biostatistics
at the University of Washington in Seattle.
Her research involves the development of statistical
machine learning methods for high dimensional
data with applications to genomics and to
other fields.
She is a recipient of numerous awards, including
an NDSEG Research Fellowship and NIH Director's
Early Independence Award, a Sloan Research
Award, and an NSF Career Award.
Her work has been featured in the popular
media and Forbes magazine, Elle magazine,
on KUOW radio, and as a PopTech Science fellow.
She is the co-author with Gareth James, Trevor
Hastie, and Rob Tibshirani of the very popular
textbook, Introduction to Statistical Learning.
She was a member of the Institute of Medicine
Committee that released the report on the
evolution of translational omics.
So her talk today will be very appropriate
to the subject of big data, computing, and
statistical learning.
Once again, I'd like to remind you that if
you have any questions for Dr. Witten during
her talk to please submit your questions via
the little question submission mechanism here
on the right side-- usually on the right side
of your display.
And we'll gather all those up and ask them
at the end of Dr. Witten's presentation.
So without further ado, Dr. Witten, thank
you very much for presenting to us today.
Thanks so much for the introduction.
And so today, as we just heard, I'm going
to talk about supervised machine learning.
And just to give you an overview, machine
learning basically falls into two camps--
supervised learning and also unsupervised
learning.
So the idea behind supervised learning is
that we use a data set, x, to predict or to
detect an association with a response, y.
So examples of supervised learning include
regression where we're trying to predict a
quantitative response, classification where
we're trying to predict a categorical response.
And you're going to hear a lot about supervised
learning today from me.
But I do briefly just want to mention that
the other big type of machine learning is
learning today from me.
But I do briefly just want to mention that
the other big type of machine learning is
unsupervised learning.
And the idea behind unsupervised learning
is that we want to discover the signal in
a matrix, X, and no y is available.
So unsupervised learning is an incredibly
important topic.
And that's actually going to be covered in
next week's webinar.
And today instead, I will just be focusing
on supervised learning.
So there's a couple different flavors of supervised
learning.
And maybe the best known flavor is regression.
So the idea behind regression is that you
want to predict a quantitative response such
as blood pressure, cholesterol level, tumor
size.
So the thing that makes regression regression
is that the response, which I'm going to call
y today, is quantitative.
So the other main flavor of supervised learning
is classification.
And in classification, we are trying to predict
a categorical response such as tumor versus
normal tissue, heart disease versus no heart
disease, subtype of disease, and so on.
So the only difference between regression
and classification is the type of your response,
y.
If it's a quantitative response, you're in
the regression framework.
If it's a categorical or qualitative response,
you're in the classification framework.
And one thing that I really want to emphasize
is that it doesn't matter what type of data
matrix, X, you have.
So as I'll mention in a couple minutes, the
idea is you have a data matrix, X, which contains
measurements for your variables or your features.
You're trying to predict this response, y.
So I don't care if your data matrix, X, is
quantitative, if it's categorical.
It doesn't matter.
It's still going to be regression if your
response, y, is quantitative.
And it'll still be classification if your
response, y, is categorical.
So regression and classification are the two
main flavors of supervised learning.
There are also other flavors like if you have
a response that's a survival time, which is
possibly censored because some people might
have died, or dropped out of the study, and
so on, then that is a slightly different flavor
of supervised learning.
But the main ideas that apply to regression
also hold for these other flavors of supervised
learning.
And so today, I'm going to just be talking
about regression.
But again, all of these ideas extend directly
to other types of quantitative responses.
So I'm going to start off talking about linear
models, because linear models give us an incredibly
flexible framework for doing regression.
And basically, if you're doing supervised
machine learning, 90% of what you need fits
within the linear model framework.
And then at the end of my talk, I'm going
to just speak for a few minutes about a really
different type of supervised learning, which
is a decision tree approach.
So to begin, we're in the linear model setting.
And the idea is that we have n observations.
And for the ith observation, I'm going to
call the response y sub i.
And I'm going to let xi1 through xiP denote
the P features for that ith observation.
So for example, yi might be blood pressure,
which is a quantitative value.
And then xi1 through xiP are a bunch of features.
Maybe these are biomarkers that we think are
predictive of blood pressure.
So we want to use these features to predict
the response.
And in a linear model, we do this as follows.
We say that yi is just equal to intercept
beta naught plus the coefficient beta 1, which
gets multiplied by the first feature, xi1
and so on all the way through to the Pth feature,
where beta P is multiplied by xiP plus a noise
term, epsilon.
So epsilon sub i is the noise term associated
with the ith observation.
And the idea is that we need to estimate these
unknown coefficients, beta naught through
beta P. In other words, we have to fit the
model.
So actually there's a lot of ways we could
fit this model.
And I'm going to start by talking about the
best known way to fit this model.
And then I'll talk about the fact that that
best known way isn't necessarily the best
approach, especially in the context of biomedical
big data.
But first, let's talk about the simplest way
to fit a linear model.
And if you took STAT 101, then you probably
saw the least squares approach for fitting
a linear model.
And the idea behind least squares is that
we look for estimates of the coefficients.
If you see a little hat on a coefficient,
that means it's an estimate.
So I'm looking for a beta naught hat, beta
1 hat, all the way through to beta P hat such
that the sum of squared errors is as small
as possible.
So I'm going to sum the quantity, yi, minus
the prediction or the fitted value for my
model.
I get that by plugging in the coefficient
estimates.
And then I'm going to square that quantity.
So this entire term here is called a sum of
squared errors.
It's also called a residual sum of squares.
And when I fit a model using these squares,
I'm just looking for these coefficient estimates
such that this residual sum of squares is
as small as possible.
A simpler way to represent this is to say
that I'm just looking for coefficient estimates
such that the sum of yi minus yi hat squared
is as small as possible where yi hat is the
prediction from my model.
Or you can also call it the fitted value from
the model.
So this is a really natural way to fit a linear
model.
And it works pretty well, especially in the
old fashioned data setting where you have
three, or five, or eight variables that you
measured and you have a huge number of observations.
So this works really well if n is large and
P is really small.
But as we'll see in a few minutes, often in
observations.
So this works really well if n is large and
P is really small.
But as we'll see in a few minutes, often in
the context of biomedical big data, least
squares is not the best way to go.
But before I get there, here's a picture showing
what least squares is actually doing.
So here is an example with the response, y,
and two predictors, x1 and x2.
So the observations are shown as red circles.
And the least squares fit to the data is a
plane.
It's that green-blue plane that you see in
the middle here.
And the reason that this is a plane is because
we have two features.
So instead of a least squares line, we have
a least squares plane.
And these black vertical bars here, they tell
us how far yi is from the prediction for yi
with our model.
So in other words, this black vertical bar
tells me the distance, yi minus yi hat.
And so this blue least squares plane is actually
exactly positioned such that the sum of yi
minus yi hat squared is as small as possible.
In other words, so that the sum of squared
black lines is as small as possible.
And you can sort of imagine that if you shifted
the plane up or down, or if you wiggled it
a little bit, then the sum of squared black
lines would actually increase.
OK.
You've probably seen least squares regression
before.
This is something that comes up like in a
classical statistics class.
But I want to talk now a little bit about
the machine learning perspective on what we're
doing.
So in machine learning when we talk about
fitting a model, we say that we're fitting
a model on a training set.
So the training set refers to the data that
you use to actually fit your model.
And given that we fit a model on the training
set, we can think about the error of our model
on the training set.
Usually we think about the mean squared error.
And you've actually seen this before.
This is just one over n times that residual
sum of squares quantity that we saw a couple
of slides ago.
So remember the way that we chose the coefficients,
beta naught hat, beta 1 hat through beta P
hat was actually just to make this quantity
as small as possible.
So we basically are guaranteed that the mean
squared error is going to be a decently small
on the training set, because we literally
chose these coefficient estimates in order
to make this mean squared error small.
But what I'm trying to emphasize here is that
this mean squared error, right now what I'm
showing you is the mean squared error calculated
on the training set.
And moving forward, I'm going to call this
the training error.
So this mean squared error, it gives me a
representation of how good my model is on
the data that I use to fit my model.
It does not give me an idea of how good my
model would be hypothetically on data that
I did not use to fit my model.
So if you're familiar with R squared from
a linear model, an R squared is just really
closely related to the training error.
When R squared is big, your training error
is small.
There's really actually a one to one mapping
between those two quantities.
So it turns out that training error, and equivalently
R squared, are not a great way to think about
how good your model is.
And the reason that they're not good is because
they will always improve as we fit a more
complex model.
So like imagine that first you fit a model
with three variables and you calculate your
training error and then you say, hey actually
maybe I should just add in one more variable
to my model.
Well your training error is going to go down.
It's literally guaranteed to go down or maybe
stay the same as you increase the number of
variables.
So training error, we can see right away,
there's kind of a problem, because it's going
to look better and better and better as we
add more and more variables to our model.
And the problem basically is that training
error quantifies the fit to the training data.
So as you fit a more and more complex model
to the training data, your model is going
to look better and better on the training
data-- actually to the point where if you
fit a complex enough model, we can get a perfect
fit to the training data with 0 error.
But the problem here is that what we really
care about is the model's performance not
on the training data, but rather on a test
set.
So for me, a model is good not if it accurately
describes the training data, but actually
if it accurately describes the test set, because
I don't really care about predicting the response
on the data that I already collected, because
I know the response on the data that I already
collected.
What I care about is predicting the response
on a new observation for which the response
is unknown that was not part of my training
set.
So if you're coming up with some way to predict
survival time on the basis of gene expression
among patients with some disease, I already
know the survival time for the patients that
I'm using to fit my model.
So doing a really great job predicting the
survival time for the patients who are in
my training set is really not useful.
But what I need to do is do a really good
job predicting survival time for a new patient
who walks into my clinic tomorrow or next
week.
And that's really the idea behind the fact
that the training error is getting at the
wrong quantity.
Instead, I need to be getting at the model's
performance on a test set.
So just to reiterate, as we fit a more complex
model-- in particular, as we increase the
number of variables-- the R
squared of our linear model will always increase
and the training error will always decrease.
So that's just really important to realize,
because it gives us an idea of the fact that
training error and R squared are telling us
the wrong thing.
So as I mentioned, what we care about is the
performance of the model on observations not
used to fit the model.
And to quantify this a little bit more, what
I really care about is the difference between
the response for a test observation and the
prediction for a test observation where here,
y hat test is the predicted value or the fitted
value that I'm going to get if I get a new
test observation and I plug the variables
for that test observation into the model that
I fit on the training set.
So the test error is the average of y test
minus y hat test squared over a bunch of test
observations.
And what I really want is a model for which
the test error is small.
And so we already saw the first two panels
of this plot showing that as the complexity
of your model increases, the R squared will
increase and the training error will decrease.
But the really critical thing here is that
the test error is not going to continue to
decrease as you make your model more and more
complex.
Actually the test error is going to bottom
out for some certain level of model complexity,
which is indicated here using a red arrow.
And after it bottoms out, it's going to start
increasing.
So you can see that in terms of test error,
you don't just want to fit an arbitrarily
complex model.
In order to make the test error small, there's
going to be some intermediate level of model
complexity.
And actually if you take one thing out of
this webinar, it should be this figure.
It should be an understanding of the fact
that the only thing that matters is test error.
Training error is just not relevant.
And if you focus on fitting your supervised
machine learning models in order to make the
training error small, then you've just totally
missed the boat, because you'll end up over
here with a tiny training error but a really
substantial test error.
So I just want to try to illustrate the problem
with thinking about training error in a small
example.
So what I'm showing here on the left is just
a small simulated dataset with a single feature,
x, on the horizontal axis and a single response,
y, on the vertical axis.
And the observations are shown in red.
And on the left is what you get if you just
fit a least squares linear model to the data.
So in this example, there is like 20 observations,
one feature.
I fit a linear model to the data using least
squares.
And what I can see is that there's clearly
like a nonzero training error here, because
these red points aren't exactly on the black
least squares line.
So the training error is nonzero.
But this looks like a pretty good model.
I can imagine that if I had a test set, like
if I were able to generate more observations
from the same distribution that made the red
observations, the test error would be pretty
modest.
This is a pretty decent fit to the data.
But now in contrast, let's look over here
on the right.
So on the right, it's the exact same setup.
But now instead of having 20 observations
like we had on the left, we just have two
observations on the right.
And I'm, again, just fitting a linear model,
just with one variable, x.
But what I see now is that I got a perfect
fit to this training data.
So my training error on the right is 0.
So we look at this picture on the right and
we see that I got 0 training error.
But this model on the right, it does not sit
well.
This model doesn't look good.
And if we imagine generating more observations
from the same distribution, we'd see this
actually is a really bad model.
Those additional observations would actually
be nowhere close to this black line, because
we overfit the data here.
We fit a model that was too complex given
the amount of data.
With only two observations, you actually can't
fit a linear model in a meaningful way.
So over here on the right, we got 0 training
error, but the test error would actually be
a huge.
So this is kind of just an intuitive explanation
of the fact that training error is not the
right thing to be looking at, because like
on the right here, the training error is 0
but we've got a really big test error.
And this is also an example on the right of
the fact that even something that seems really
simple like a least squares linear model can
actually be too complex for the data, and
in a little example with just two observations.
So one thing that I just keep on referring
to offhand is this notion of model complexity.
Model complexity is actually central to absolutely
everything in supervised learning.
As model complexity increases, training error
will decrease.
And I've kind of offhand been talking about
how we can increase the number of variables
in our model and then the model will get more
complex.
But actually, the notion of model complexity
is much more general than just the number
of variables in the model.
And we're actually going to see in a few minutes
when we look at rigid regression an example
of a model that might include a lot of variables.
But it's not such a complex model.
So in other words, if it's convenient for
you to think about model complexity as like
the number of variables in the model, then
you should just remember that that's one way
you can think about model complexity.
But it's often not the best way.
And model complexity actually is more general
than just the number of variables in your
model.
OK.
So as model complexity increases, training
error will decrease.
But the test error might not.
I already said this one.
OK.
So just to explain in a little more detail
what's happening in terms of the model complexity,
there's really two things we need to think
about when we think about how good a model
is.
So the first thing is bias.
So the bias is beta hat.
It's the average difference between beta and
beta hat if we were to repeat the experiment
a huge number of times.
So bias is basically telling us, how good
is our model on average?
And as we said, in increasingly complex model,
the bias is going to decrease.
So this is really good, because I was just
saying that as we get a more complex model,
on average, our model is going to be better
and better and better.
And that's great, because I want a really
good model.
So that suggests that I should fit a really
complex model.
But there's a problem, which is that it turns
out I don't just care about bias.
I also care about something called variance.
And the variance of beta hat is the amount
by which the beta hats will differ across
the experiments.
So imagine that I repeated an experiment a
huge number of times.
And I calculated beta hat every time.
So the variance of beta hat is just the amount
by which these estimates of beta would vary
across the experiments.
And the problem is that if I fit an increasingly
complex model, the variance of beta hat is
going to increase.
And the test error, which is the thing that
I really care about, is actually the square
of the bias plus the variance.
So the thing that happens here is that there's
a trade off between bias and variance, because
as I increase the model complexity, the squared
bias is going to decrease.
So that's really good.
But the variance is going to increase.
And that's really bad.
And so typically, if your model complexity
is really, really, really low, your bias is
going to be huge.
And your variance is going to be small.
But the sum of something huge and the sum
of something small is still huge.
So that's bad.
And if you fit a super complex model, the
bias is going to be really small.
But the variance will be huge.
And again, the sum of something small plus
huge is really huge.
And typically, for some intermediate level
of model complexity, you can make both of
these relatively small simultaneously.
And that'll make your test error small.
And that's the sweet spot.
So what we want is a level of model complexity
that makes this sum, and consequently the
test error, small.
So in other words, we need a model with small
bias and also small variance.
So you can see this bias-variance trade off
in a picture.
Model complexity from low to high is on the
x-axis.
Error is on the y-axis.
You can see training error in blue, test error
in red.
So you can see the training error is monotone
decreasing in model complexity.
But the test error is not.
The smallest test error is happening right
here for an intermediate level of model complexity.
And this figure also shows you that as you
get a more complex model, the bias is decreasing.
But the variance is increasing.
And for a less complex model, the bias is
increasing and the variance is decreasing.
So hopefully by now you are on the same page
as me that test set error is the thing that
we care about.
So if we want to make sure that we're fitting
a model with a small test set error, then
we need a way to estimate the test set error.
And basically there are three ways that we
can estimate the test error.
And as you'll see, they're actually all pretty
similar.
So the first one is the validation set approach.
And the idea behind the validation set approach
is that you have your n observations.
You split them into two sets.
Train your model on one set and then calculate
the test error on the other set.
So the validation set approach is great.
It's very easy to implement.
The only problem is that you arbitrarily are
splitting your data into two sets.
And if you had done a different split of the
data, you might get a slightly different estimate
of test error.
People don't really like that.
So to overcome that problem, we can do an
approach called leave-one-out cross-validation.
And the idea behind leave-one-out cross-validation
is that we have our n observations.
We fit a model using all but the first observation.
So you can see we're leaving out the first
observation in this top row here, fitting
a model on the remaining observations, and
then calculate the test error on the first
observation.
Next we fit a model on all but the second
observation and evaluate the test error on
the second observation.
And so on.
We do this n times.
Each time, we fit the model on all but one
of the observations.
And we test on the remaining observation.
Then we average the error rates that we get.
And that gives us a really good estimate of
the test error.
So leave-one-out cross-validation is really
nice.
It's very systematic.
It feels thorough, because we leave out every
observation one at a time.
But the problem is that often, it's computationally
undesirable, because we have to fit n models
in order to get an estimate of our model complexity.
And if n is a really big number, like we have
a really big sample size in our study, then
this isn't going to fly.
So typically, the preferred approach is something
called k-fold cross-validation.
And here I'm showing you an
example of k-fold cross-validation with k
equals five.
And the idea is that we split the observations
into five sets.
And we're repeatedly going to train the model
on four sets and evaluate its performance
on the fifth.
So for example right here, in blue, you can
see my training set.
I'm going to fit the model on the training
set, evaluate the test error on this test
set in orange.
And then I'm going to repeat.
But I'm going to be changing each time which
set of observations I'm considering to be
the test set.
Average those five error rates.
And that gives us an estimate of our test
error.
So it's really up to you how you want to estimate
test error.
Leave-one-out cross-validation, the validation
set approach, and k-fold cross-validation
are all perfectly fine.
The important thing is that when you fit a
model, you need to check what its test error
is, because you don't want to accidentally
come up with a model that has a great training
error but a very poor test error.
OK.
So far, we've talked about linear models that
we fit using least squares.
But as I have alluded to, often least squares
regression is not a great choice of model.
And this can basically happen for two reasons.
It can happen because the least squares model
is not complex enough or because it's too
complex.
So I'm going to talk in a couple minutes about
what we do if a least squares model is not
complex enough for our data.
But actually typically, what we see in big
biomedical data is that the least squares
model is too complex in the sense that there
are too many features relative to the number
of observations.
So for example, suppose that I want to predict
a patient's response to chemotherapy.
And my predictors are things like the expression
levels for a whole lot of genes, maybe for
20,000 genes, protein levels where I've assayed
some huge number of proteins, or maybe I've
done DNA sequencing on genes that are potentially
implicated in breast cancer.
So in each of these situations, chances are
we have a huge number of features or variables
that we're using as predictors in our model.
And if we fit a least squares model in this
setting, we're actually going to get really
bad test error.
Our training error would look awesome, but
the test error would be really bad, because
we'd be overfitting the data.
So if we fit a model that's too complex, then
that's known as overfitting.
Basically a model that has a low training
error but a high test error is a model that
we've overfit to the data.
So typically, least squares is going to overfit
the data in the context of big biomedical
data.
And so what we need is
an alternative to least squares.
We need a way to fit a linear model, but somehow
get less complexity than we get if we fit
least squares using the P variables.
So ridge regression and the lasso are two
methods for fitting a linear model that are
alternatives to least squares.
And they yield a less complex model by shrinking
the regression coefficients.
And so as we're going to see, these are really
just minor modifications to the least squares
fitting approach.
But they can give us much better results in
cases when least squares fits too complex
of a model.
So ridge regression and the lasso are examples
of what are known as regularization approaches
or penalization approaches.
And there are many other examples of such
methods.
But I'm just going to focus on ridge regression
and the lasso today, because those are the
two best known approaches.
I also just want to mention that these regularization
approaches are actually a topic of extensive
contemporary research in statistical machine
learning today.
OK.
So first of all, ridge regression.
The idea behind ridge regression is that we're
looking for coefficients, beta naught through
beta P, that minimize our residual sum of
squares.
So this is just like what we had in the least
squares setting.
But also there's an additional term here,
which is a tuning parameter lambda times the
sum over the features of beta j squared.
So again, this is just like the least squares
optimization problem except that now there
is an additional term.
And so here, lambda is a non-negative tuning
parameter.
We can see right away that if lambda is 0,
then this term just disappears and we're just
fitting a least squares model.
But as we increase lambda, this term is going
to tend to decrease.
The sum of beta j hat squared is going to
decrease.
And basically the way that you can think about
it is that there are two terms.
This first term quantifies how well I'm fitting
the training data.
And this term quantifies how complex my model
is.
You can actually think of sum of beta j squared
as a way to quantify your model complexity.
So when lambda is really small or when lambda
is 0, I'm just focusing on getting a really
good fit to the training data with this lost
term.
But when lambda is bigger, I'm going to be
focusing more on getting a really simple model
or a model that's not too complex with this
penalty term.
And actually in the limit, when lambda becomes
arbitrarily large, you can see that these
beta j's are going to actually approach 0,
because if lambda is just super huge, then
you're going to want your sum of beta j squares
to be really tiny so that this penalty term
doesn't get too big.
So you can see that lambda really controls
the complexity of your model.
When lambda is really big, you're going to
get a really, really, really simple model
with just tiny coefficient estimates.
So this plot gives you a graphical representation
of what ridge regression gives you as you
vary the tuning parameter, lambda.
So here I am showing lambda on the x-axis.
The y-axis shows coefficients.
And this is a little example data set with
a bunch of features, most of which are small.
And those are shown in gray.
And then four features that are larger are
shown in various colors.
So in order to understand this figure, let's
take a look over here all the way on the left
side where my cursor is.
So lambda is around 0.01 here.
And when lambda is 0.01, like the black coefficient
is around negative 280, the red one is around
420.
But as I increase lambda, for example as I
make lambda equal to one right here, the black
coefficient is slightly smaller.
The red coefficient is slightly smaller.
OK.
These coefficients are slightly smaller.
And as I make lambda really big, take a look
over here.
Like when lambda is 100, now all the coefficients
are quite a bit smaller.
And over here where lambda is 10,000, all
the coefficients are really close to 0.
So when we perform ridge regression, our results
are actually a function of this tuning parameter,
lambda.
And if you want to know what would happen
with a given value of lambda, you just go
to that position on the x-axis.
And you look at the value of the coefficients
for that particular lambda.
So over here, we're fitting a really simple
model with very low variance, because all
the coefficients are 0.
That's very low variance, but it's going to
have big bias.
So overall, the test error is going to be
really big.
Over here, probably the test error is going
to be big also, because this model has low
bias but high variance over here.
And over here, things are more intermediate.
So probably the best value of the test error
is going to be around here.
But in order to find out, we'd have to use
one of the approaches that I mentioned earlier
for estimating the test error.
So one thing that I want you to notice is
that over here when lambda is really big,
all those coefficients become very close to
0.
But they're actually not exactly 0.
Maybe they're like 10 to the negative three
or something.
We can't quite see in this figure.
But none of the coefficients are exactly 0.
They're just becoming closer and closer to
0.
So in practice, when you're performing ridge
regression, you're going to choose the tuning
parameter in order to minimize the test error.
And then the value of lambda that we want
is the one with the smallest test error.
And then
we would run ridge regression on the full
data using that same value of lambda.
So what I mean by this is like suppose you're
choosing lambda using the validation set approach.
So you fit the model on half of the observations
for a bunch of values of lambda, evaluate
each of those models on the other half of
the observations, identify the value of lambda
that gave you the smallest error rate.
And now using that value of lambda, you need
to rerun ridge regression on all of the observations.
So the important thing to know about ridge
regression is that while it can give us a
model that's not very complex when lambda
is large, that final model is going to contain
all of the variables no matter what.
And sometimes this isn't desirable.
So like imagine that you're trying to come
up with a way to use gene expression values
to predict a patient's survival time.
You might want to develop that model using
all 20,000 genes.
But at the end of the day, you might want
your final model to only involve a handful
of genes, because a final model involving
just a handful of genes would be easier to
translate into clinical practice, for example.
It would be less expensive to come up with
a diagnostic involving just 20 genes rather
than a diagnostic involving 20,000 genes.
So if we want to fit a model that involves
just a subset of the features, then ridge
regression isn't going to take us there.
So instead, we can do what's called the lasso.
A lasso is just a small tweak to ridge regression
that gives us a model with mostly 0 elements.
So in other words, the resulting model is
sparse.
And another way to phrase this is we can say
that the lasso performs feature selection.
So this is the optimization problem for the
lasso.
We're going to look for coefficients that
minimize, once again, this residual sum of
squares term that by now you've seen a lot
of times, plus a penalty.
This looks just like the ridge regression
penalty with just one difference.
In ridge regression, we had a beta j squared
term here.
Now I've got an absolute value of beta j.
And this is a really small difference.
And it seems like it shouldn't matter.
But actually the difference is small, but
important, because whereas ridge regression
never gives you any coefficient estimates
exactly equal to 0, the lasso will.
So like ridge regression, we've got this tuning
parameter, lambda, that controls model complexity.
When lambda equals 0, we're just back at least
squares.
But most importantly, for an intermediate
value of lambda, we can actually get some
coefficient estimates that are exactly equal
to 0.
And that's the whole reason to ever do the
lasso is if you want coefficient estimates
that are exactly 0-- in other words, if you
want a sparse model.
So when lambda is very large, the sum of the
beta j hats will be exactly 0.
In contrast to ridge regression, where the
best you'll ever see is the sum of the beta
j hats might be close to 0.
So we saw a figure like this for ridge regression.
And now here's the same figure for the lasso.
And what I want you to notice here is for
example, check out what happens when lambda
is 500.
So if lambda equals 500, the black coefficient
is nonzero.
The yellow, red, and blue ones are nonzero.
But all of these gray coefficients have estimates
that are exactly 0.
So right here with lambda equals 500, my lasso
model only involves four features.
So this is really nice, because it means that,
again, if I'm trying to develop a predictor
of response to chemotherapy, my predictive
model here only involves four of my 20,000
features.
And that's pretty great in a lot of settings.
If instead I had lambda equals 5,000, now
I have a fitted model that only involves the
blue feature.
All the other features are exactly 0.
So again, as we saw with ridge regression,
I've got to choose this parameter, lambda.
The way that I typically would choose it would
be based on estimating the test error using
one of those approaches that we saw a few
minutes ago.
And that would tell us what value of lambda
to use.
But for example, if that approach told us
to choose lambda over here, then our final
model would involve only four features.
OK.
So that's it for ridge regression and the
lasso.
I want to just briefly very fast mention another
approach for fitting a linear model that you
may have heard of.
And this is called principle components regression.
And it's really a different take on how we
can fit a less complex model than what we
get using least squares.
So the idea behind principal components regression
is as usual, we have n observations and P
features.
What that means is that our observations live
in a P dimensional space.
But it turns out that not all those dimensions
are equally useful.
So for example, some of the dimensions might
be completely redundant with each other.
And that would be the case if our features
are highly correlated.
Other dimensions might be uninformative.
And that would correspond to noise features.
So the question is, can we find a low dimensional
representation of the variables that captures
most of the action?
So instead of having to deal with P dimensions,
can we actually just find n dimensions that
do a pretty good job of capturing what's happening
in the data?
So this is broadly referred to as a dimension
reduction approach.
There are a lot of dimension reduction approaches
out there.
The two best known such approaches are principal
components regression and partial least squares.
And right now, I'm just going to mention principal
components regression.
But if you've heard of partial least squares,
then it's a similar type of approach.
So the idea behind principal components regression
is that I'm going to look for the variables
that I'll call z1 through zn.
And these are linear combinations of my original
P predictors.
So in other words, I'm looking for coefficients,
[INAUDIBLE] mj, such that zm is just a linear
combination of x's.
And then once I've identified these new dimensions,
z1 through zm, I'm just going to fit a least
squares model.
But instead of fitting the model using my
original features, I'm going to fit the model
with my new features, z1 through zm.
So this is really simple.
I'm just telling you do least squares, but
don't use the original features.
Use new features.
OK.
Well what are these new features supposed
to be?
Well these new features should be the principal
components of the data.
So I'm telling you to take the first m principal
components of your data.
Fit a least squares model using those as features.
And you're done.
You just did principal components regression.
OK.
So what are principal components?
Well you're going to see these in more detail
next week in the webinar on unsupervised learning.
But the idea behind principal components is
that they're linear combinations of your variables
that contain as much variability of your data
as possible.
So they're basically just a low dimensional
representation of your data that captures
as much of the variability as possible.
So in an example with two variables and observations
shown in purple, this green line represents
the first principal component.
And you can see the first principal component
is sort of the direction along which your
data varies the most.
So if I had to summarize these purple observations
in just one dimension, then this green line
would give me the best possible summary.
So the idea is when you do principal components
regression, you're actually getting a model
that's linear in the original predictors.
So it is a linear model in the original predictors.
But it's not the same as the least squares
model that you get if you ran these squares
on the original predictors.
You're actually getting a much less complex
model, provided that m is less than P.
It's important to know that principal components
regression doesn't involve feature selection
in the sense that all
of the original predictors are involved in
your final model.
The number of principal components that you
have controls model complexity.
So if m equals P, you're just back at least
squares.
If m is smaller than P, you're going to get
a less complex model.
And as usual, we're going to decide on the
level of level of model complexity by minimizing
the test error.
OK.
And then just as an aside, principal components
regression is actually very, very similar
to ridge regression in terms of the underlying
mathematics.
And PCR works well in a lot of settings.
But sometimes it fails.
And really the reason for this is because
there's no guarantee that the first m principal
components will be predictive of the response,
because the first m principal components will
definitely explain a lot of the variation
in the features.
But they might not be predictive of the response.
OK.
So this whole discussion of ridge regression,
the lasso, and principal components regression
have focused on giving you a model that's
less complex than least squares.
And again, that's because in the case of biomedical
big data, usually least squares is too complex
of a model in the sense that you don't have
enough observations and you have a huge number
of features.
But if it turns out that you're actually in
a setting where you want a more complex model,
like maybe you've just measured a dozen features
and you have 20,000 observations, then don't
worry.
Least squares has got you covered.
You can just fit a least squares model-- oops
I'm sorry.
This is a typo.
It should say we can fit a linear model using
transformations of your features.
So if you want to, you could perform least
squares using features xj, xj squared, xj
cubed, P to the xj.
You could even take products of your features
like xj with xk and so on.
And in order to fit the model, you could use
least squares.
Or you could actually perform ridge, lasso,
and so on.
So it's always easy to make a model more complex
by just throwing in new features, or combinations,
or transformations of your old features.
And that's why I haven't really focused on
how to get a more complex model, because typically,
that's a pretty easy task.
Just remember that if you're considering a
complex model, you've got to estimate your
test error.
OK.
Briefly, I've been talking about regression.
Classification is when you have a categorical
or a qualitative response.
And the reason I haven't talked about classification
is because it's easy.
Everything that I've talked about for regression,
it applies exactly the same way to classification.
So once you get it with regression, you're
going to understand classification too.
All of the same ideas apply.
OK.
Well I'm really almost out of time.
But I just want to spend two minutes talking
about a fun topic, which is decision trees.
So everything that I've mentioned so far is
within the framework of a linear model.
But of course, there's other ways you can
do supervised learning too.
And a really fun one is a decision tree.
So the idea behind a decision tree is that
you are going to partition the range of x
into boxes.
And then you're going to make a prediction
within each box.
So decision tree models are very interpretable.
And to show you how interpretable it is, we
can look at an example.
So this is just a toy dataset.
And what we're going to do is predict a baseball
player's salary based on various characteristics.
So here is a regression tree for this baseball
dataset.
And so here is how you read it.
You start at the top and you say, all right.
If this player's been playing baseball for
less than four and a half years, we're going
to go to the left.
And if they've been playing for more than
four and a half years, we're going to go to
the right.
So whenever there is a branch or whenever
there's a split rather, if the answer is yes,
you're going to go to the left.
And if it's no, you'll go to the right.
So let's say that there is a player who has
been playing for less than four and a half
years.
OK.
We're going to go down to the left.
And if this player batted in fewer than 60
runs last season, we're going to go out to
the left again.
If they had more than 82 put outs, we're going
to go to the right.
All right.
Now we've got to check.
Have they been playing for more then or fewer
than three and a half years?
And if they've been playing for more than
three and a half years, then my prediction
of their salary is 5.183.
So this is actually on the log scale and it's
in thousands of dollars.
So to figure out how many dollars this is,
multiply or rather calculate e to the 5.183.
And then multiply by 1,000.
And the reason that this is on the log scale
is just because it's better to model salary
on a log scale than on a linear scale.
So alternatively, if the player who you want
to pick salary for has played for more than
four and a half years and they did more than
or 117.5 hits last season and fewer than 52.5
walks, then they actually are going to have
substantially higher salary-- e to the 6.549
thousands of dollars per year.
So regression trees are really great, because
you don't need to know any math.
You don't need a computer to
understand them.
Like imagine you're working in an emergency
room and there might just be some regression
tree.
And this can just be like pasted on the wall
of the nurse's station and it gives nurses
a really quick way to just look up a patient's
characteristics and then get the prediction
that they need.
So decision trees are interpretable.
The whole reason to ever use a decision is
because you want a picture like this, because
you want something like this that you can
show to someone who either doesn't want to
have to figure out all the math or just doesn't
have time and they need something quick that
they can look at.
Regression trees typically are not as accurate
as other approaches to supervised learning.
But they are interpretable.
So if you care about interpretability, then
great.
And if you don't care about interpretability,
this is not a good choice, because you can
do better in terms of accuracy using other
methods.
So I just want to show in a little more detail
how do we get this tree.
Well suppose that our only variables were
the number of hits last season and the number
of years that the player has been playing.
So what we do is we partition feature space
in a very particular way in order to get these
three regions, R1, R3, and R2.
And then to get the prediction within the
region, R1, we just take the average of the
observations in this region.
To get the prediction within R3, we average
those observations.
And to get the prediction within this region,
we average those observations.
And that gives us a tree that looks like this,
where the number reported here is the average
within the regions, R1, R2, and R3.
OK.
So when you're building a decision tree, you
can decide how big you want your tree to be.
A large tree is going to tend to overfit the
data.
A small tree is going to underfit the data.
And we typically want to use the test error
in order to determine what's the best tree
size.
So for example on the baseball data, on the
left we have a really big tree.
On the right, we have a much smaller tree.
The one on the left is going to have low bias
but high variance.
The one on the right is going to have low
variance but possibly high bias.
And the way that we would choose which tree
we want is by estimating the test error.
OK.
So I just want to close with maybe one final
comment, which I don't have time to go into
detail.
But this comment is basically that it doesn't
matter how fancy the machine learning is that
you're doing.
You always have to think about just the underlying
science and the experimental design.
And in particular, one really big problem
that we see within the context of big biomedical
data is issues called batch effects.
And batch effects can occur if there's some
kind of variability in your data that results
from nonbiological factors.
Batch effects are a huge problem in biological
data.
And there's only so much that you can do in
order to deal with them.
In order to avoid having batch effects invalidate
your results, it's really important to have
good experimental design.
So you should randomize your sample run times.
For example, you don't want to run the cases
first and then the controls.
You should try to avoid having batch effects
in the first place by reducing the extraneous
sources of variation in your experiment.
Typically, it's better if when you fit a model,
you fit the model on multiple data sets collected
in different labs or different institutions
rather than on a single dataset.
And really most importantly, it's really important
that you validate any results that you get
on independent datasets collected in a different
lab or in a different institution.
Because otherwise, the presence of batch effects
in your data could make your results look
really good.
Even your test error could look really good.
But if you had evaluated test error on an
independent dataset, it might not look so
good.
OK.
And then finally, the last thing I want to
say is if you're doing supervised machine
learning, there is no best approach.
There's a lot of ways you can do it.
I've talked about a number of methods for
a supervised machine learning.
But there's literally textbooks that are just
filled with supervised machine learning approaches.
But what I want to emphasize is that there
is no best way.
Sometimes one approach is going to work better
than another.
And so we can't say that one approach is best.
But we can say that some approaches are wrong.
So for example, you could do cross-validation
wrong.
And then your test error estimate would be
And you'd be choosing a really bad model.
So no approach is best, but some approaches
are wrong.
And if you get one thing from this lecture,
the thing that you get should be that test
error is really important, and that you've
got to make sure that you're calculating it
right.
Because a model that has a high test error
is just really meaningless and not useful
actually in any context.
Great.
It looks like a lot of time.
That's it, and I'm happy to answer questions.
Thank you so much, Daniela.
That was really a great overview of statistical
learning, supervised in contrast to what we'll
hear about next week.
I think one of the themes that ran through
your presentation was really how, with our
modeling techniques, we struggle with that
curse of dimensionality.
And we've had a series of questions basically
relating to this.
Is there an assumption with all the dimensionality
that we have and the complexity of these models
that the underlying distributional properties
are normally distributed and Gaussian?
Or how much can we deviate from that and still
be able to get good estimates?
Yeah.
OK.
So Gaussianity is typically not a huge issue
in my opinion.
So like if you took your intro stats class
and you learned about linear models, you probably
were told that you should assume that the
errors are normally distributed.
And it turns out that's just not a huge assumption.
It's not a big deal if your errors aren't
normal.
You're probably fine as long as you have a
big sample size.
But where you really run into trouble is when
your sample size is small relative to the
number of features you have or relative to
the amount of complexity of the model you're
trying to fit.
And if your model is just too complex for
the available data, it doesn't matter what
distribution your data has.
You're just in trouble.
So the bottom line is that model complexity
is incredibly important.
In that question, you used the phrase curse
of dimensionality.
And curse of dimensionality is just a very
evocative phrase to describe this phenomenon
that I've mentioned, which is that a more
complex model, it can be a curse.
Like if you measure more variables, don't
just assume that more data is better data,
because more data just makes you tempted to
have a more complex model.
And that can just lead to a high test error.
So the bottom line remains you just got to
think about test error.
More complex is not better.
Low test error is better.
Right.
So I think when a lot of people are building
their models, particularly using like a linear
regression-based type of thing, and they look
at some sort of overall measure of fit or
overall amount of variance accounted for,
for example, they typically want to look at
the overall statistical significance of that
model.
Like using an s statistic or something.
And the degrees of freedom sort of capture
that model of complexity about those variables
which are in the model versus those which
are part of the error term.
How does that act as a governor on those tests?
And if that's not still acceptable, are there
alternatives like information-based metrics
that one could use as a measure of overall
fit that may be more appropriate?
OK.
That's a great question.
So there are a couple parts to that.
So first of all, if you want to know how complex
your model is, however you phrase the question,
I'm always going to give you the same answer,
which is the test error is the best way to
figure out how well your model fits the data
and how complex it is.
Because there's all kinds of papers about
different methods, information, theoretic
methods, and so on.
But at the end of the day, like if I'm fitting
a predictive model, what I want is a model
that fits a test observation well.
Done.
There's literally nothing else that I care
about.
So test error is simple.
It's intuitive.
And it gets at what you want.
Really I can't think of any example in a supervised
learning context where you'd care about anything
else other than test error.
Now another question that was part of that
was, how can we actually quantify model complexity?
[INAUDIBLE] degrees of freedom.
And as you know, if you fit a linear model
using least squares, you can actually just
quantify model complexity by just counting
the number of variables in your model.
So you fit a least squares model with 10 variables.
You used up 10 degrees of freedom.
Done.
Unfortunately, as soon as you move away from
least squares to ridge regression, the lasso,
principle components regression, decision
trees, you can no longer just count up the
number of variables that you're using.
So a really good way to see that is in the
context of ridge regression.
Like ridge regression, no matter what value
of the tuning parameter you have, you're always
going to be using all P variables.
So clearly, just counting the number of variables
in your model is not a good way to quantify
model complexity.
So model complexity, if you want to just say
like what's the complexity of model A versus
model B where one is like a decision tree
and one is a lasso model, that's actually
really a challenging thing to quantify.
And I wouldn't typically recommend just trying
to go head to head between two models and
figuring out which is more or less complex.
Instead, I would, again, go back to test error.
And I would just choose the model with the
lowest test error, because test error is a
universal quantity you can compare across
models of very different types.
Great.
Well we've run out of time, unfortunately.
I'd like to encourage everybody who does have
questions for Dr. Witten, I'm sure that you
can find her email address.
It was on the kind of front of her slide set
there.
And if you were to write to her with any questions,
I'm sure she'd be delighted to answer them.
Once again, thank you, Dr. Witten, for giving
a great lecture on supervised statistical
learning.
Very appropriate to big data in a lot of contexts
for our listeners.
And once again, thank you.
And thank you, everybody.
And we'll see you again next week.
Thank you.